hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to see Korra
episode two it paid homage to a really
big Last Airbender episode and had like
a really big reveal that made everyone
fall out of their chairs at New York
Comic Con in case you missed it the
Korra panel was yesterday I posted the
whole video so I will add a link to that
in the description it's about a half an
hour long I'll explain all the important
stuff that Bryke said after my review so
careful for spoilers from the episode in
case you haven't seen it yet I'll wait
just a sec okay ready here we go top
five moments number five Korra alone the
title of the episode is omage to the
last airbender episode Zuko alone that
was booked to Episode seven both of
these episodes are about not being able
to run away from your identity in that
last airbender episode Zuko just decides
he's better off on his own and tries to
pretend like he's not the Prince of the
Fire Nation
like he tries to leave his past behind
eventually something happens and he
realizes he can't run from who he is
it's the exact same thing for Korra she
can't run from her identity as the
avatar she just keeps hallucinating
herself in the Avatar State the vision
literally changed itself to her I loved
that they did explain why she was in
that fighting ring from the scene that
we saw at the end episode one she
basically went in feeling like she was
gonna face herself she wasn't part of
some underground MMA ring like she
hasn't been doing this for a long time I
do wonder if she would have stayed in
that fighting ring head she won against
herself that's not really the point
though her true self is always gonna win
out for those wondering about Korra
reconnecting with her past lives the
title of the episode says it all Mike
and Bryan just really wanted core to be
on her own in the book for she can't
turn inward for guidance or quick
answers anymore that doesn't mean she
won't ever be able to reconnect with
them but at least for now
she's completely on her own number four
the flashback so we finally saw what
that teaser clip came from right after
the book 3 finale and we got an awesome
Katara scene I love the Qataris still
such a really important person in the
water tribe she's still like the best
physical and spiritual doctor ever so of
course Kors gonna go to her for healing
the big twist right now is that Breck
had always differentiated Korra from egg
in the Korra was a gung ho
Tarr like she always wanted to be the
Avatar Aang ran from it at first so it
took him like the entire last airbender
series to come to terms with who he was
like if you remember a chorus first line
when she was like a little kid was I'm
the avatar you have to deal with it
obviously that's changed now based on
Qatar's explanation it just seems like
Korra is suffering PTSD she can fix the
physical trauma to her body but she
won't be able to consciously enter the
Avatar state until she fixes the
emotional trauma and for those asking
yes I do think if she were in another
life-threatening situation her body
would automatically enter the Avatar
state like Wednesday here was poisoning
her right now that's the only way I
think she can enter the Avatar State I'm
curious to see how many more episodes
it's gonna be before she actually fixes
that problem number three Korra does
Star Wars Franken yetsko is a huge Star
Wars fan so if you were getting Empire
Strikes Back vibes from parts of the
episode it was intentional during that
New York Comic Con panel whenever they
were explaining kuvira's army they
specifically said that some of the
designs were based on stormtroopers and
GI Joes from the 1980s cartoon Mike and
Brian grew up in the 80s like a lot of
us so just like every other person in
the world at that time they were
influenced by those properties so of
course it's gonna show up in Korra but
just to explain the Empire Strikes Back
thing I'm talking about Korra marching
through the snow to the spirit portal
looking for guidance it just reminded me
of Luke Skywalker on Hoth getting the
vision of obi-wan telling him to go to
the swamps of Dagobah to learn from a
very wise master of the force so
eventually Korra follows one of the
spirits to the earth Kingdom swamps to
find Toph but she doesn't really realize
it till it's max or right in the face
I do kind of love that it becomes a
literal metaphor like Cora's past
literally smacks her in the face
number two Korra searches for raava the
massive road trip she went on was just a
lot of fun because we finally got to see
the Fire Nation again I mean we saw it a
little bit during book three with Zuko
but we haven't really been there during
Legend of Korra and her running into the
fish vendor with the portrait of ink was
probably one of the funniest moments on
Korra in awhile I love that Mike and
Bryan leave Aang unchanged like Aang
still had that silly sense of humor even
after he and Katara started their family
the aim flashbacks in book 1 made
seemed like he was really serious even
though Toph still called him twinkle
toes that's why meelo is one of my
favorite characters just because he has
so much of egg in his sense of humor and
finally my number one moment of course
melon Lord is back everyone let me know
whenever they figured out the who part
whenever that spirit said I brought you
here to find a who not on what because
of all the Empire Strikes Back stuff
I've been thinking about I kept
wondering if Toph was gonna be like a
Yoda character living in a swamp so when
the spirit said I brought you here to
find out who I was like yep probably
gonna be tough just in case you were
wondering the voice actress who was
playing Toph was fully sampler it just
continues the tradition of them using
different voice actors to do older
versions of Last Airbender people the
real question now is what has tough been
doing in that swamp all this time and
what is she gonna do with Korra to help
her reconnect with raava Toph is a
really funny character but if you
remember until she met aang and team
avatar she lived a very solitary life
like she spent most of her time hanging
out with the badger-moles and
prizefighting
all hail melon Lord who else is hoping
that we get like some sort of epic Toft
bending moment I mean this is all about
the Korra characters like the new
characters but I'm really hoping we get
like an original team avatar bending
moment like maybe they'll let her smash
up a bunch of the mechs or something
like that let me know though what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and what do you think Toph has been
doing in that swamp this whole time
overall I gave the episode a solid a
just for going in a vastly different
direction from the current series with
this side story and being able to pay
homage to some really classic moments
from last airbender Mike and Bryan are
really good about trying new things with
Korra characters but they are always
happy to do a little fanservice whenever
it's appropriate they have said in
interviews in the past that they do love
to bring those Last Airbender characters
back but because episodes are only about
22 minutes each they just don't have
time to include everything they want if
Korra were like an hour-long show or we
got 22 episodes a season you'd see more
episodes like this where we just follow
a single character for an entire episode
because so much stuff happened this week
I'll totally be doing a Q&A tomorrow so
be sure to leave all your questions and
subscribe to get that video and just to
explain what they said during the New
York Comic Con panel kuvira is the
confirmed Big Bad of the season they've
spent a lot of time talking about
the concept of the character and the
inspiration for the new metalbending
army I feel like that was the most
important thing they said like there's
not some shadowy figure that they're
gonna whip out at the end of the season
i mean kuvira is the big bad it's all in
that New York Comic Con video you can
click here right now to watch it and you
can click here for my Korra episode 1
video thank you so much for watching now
let's all high five and we watch the
episode cuckoo toes
[Music]